Welcome to week five in the Robot Vision Project.
Just to remind you all, the objective of this
project is to find the 2D position of the
objects on the Robotic Vision worksheet.
The first step in dong this is to construct
what we call a homography. I've written a
function that allows me to do this, so let's
take a look now in MATLAB at what the output
looks like. Alright so the task this week
is to write two different MATLAB functions.
The first function is called "getCalibration."
So if we pull up the Robotic Vision worksheet,
as you can see here, there are nine blue circles
on the Robotic Vision worksheet. Okay?
Now the position of these circles is going
to allow us to rectify this image such that
we can identify the X and Y Cartesian co-ordinates
of the other coloured shapes on this page.
So what my getCalibration function is going
to do, is it's going to find the nine blue
circled blobs in this image. So how my getCalibration
function works is that it returns the blue
circle blobs as an object, which is called
"Circles" in this case and we call my function
called "getCalibration" and the input to this
function is the binary image from the blue
color channel, which I've called "b2d" and
b2d was generated from my getColor function.
So if I execute that, then that extracts out
the nine blue circles as you can see here.
And then we can use the plot function which
will mark the centroids on my Robotic Vision
worksheet and this allows us to check to make
sure that the nine circles that I've identified
are actually the nine blue circles within
the Robotic Vision worksheet.
Okay, so this function allows us to locate the blue circled blobs on the Robotic Vision worksheet page.
Second function that you need to write is
called "getHomography." So from the Robotic
Vision worksheet we've extracted the position
of the blue circles in the pixel co-ordinate
frame because we've done that with the circle
blobs and the other piece of information that
we know is that we can measure the X and Y
Cartesian co-ordinates of the circles with a ruler.
So using these two pieces of information,
the position of the pixel co-ordinates and
also the position of the circles in X and
Y Cartesian co-ordinates, we can then generate
what we call a homography between these two
pieces of information.
So how does my getHomography function work?
Okay, so my getHomography function returns
two variables; the first is H, which is the
homography matrix and it also returns the
position of the circles in a particular order
and I'll talk about that in a second.
So I can call my getHomography function and
my function itself has two inputs. The first
are the circle blobs, which I've generated
with getCalibration and the second piece of
information is called P1. Now P1 is the X
and Y Cartesian co-ordinates of the circles
on the Robotic Vision worksheet that you can
measure. So after I run that, I get back my
H matrix, which is my homography and if we
look at the difference between P2 and P1,
P1 is the X and Y Cartesian co-ordinate positions
that I've measured with a ruler and these
are in millimeters and P2 is the ordered list
of points that I've gotten back with respect
to P1 and they're in pixel co-ordinates.
Now the reason why the ordering is important
is that if you go back to the Robotic Vision
worksheet, you can see that there is one circle
which is larger than the others. And this
circles here, you will need to use to identify
where the X axis is on this image. Because
if your Robotic Vision worksheet image was
rotated, you wouldn't know where exactly the
X axis was, so you need to also locate where
this large circle is, such that you can order
the groups of points of P1 and P2 in the correct
order that they need to be in. Now I've combined
both of these functions in a script, which
I've called "prac_mark". So let's take a look at that now.
Okay, so this is the output from my prac_mark
script. So I've two figures here as you can
see and the left hand sided figure is the
rectified image of the original Robotic Vision
worksheet image. And you can see that it's
been rectified such that it's been rotated
90 degrees. And that came about through my
getHomography function. And why I did that
was because I wanted to align the X and Y
Cartesian co-ordinate axis with the pixel
co-ordinate axis of the rectified image as
you can see here. So this is why the ordering
of the points is important.
So you can see on the left, the ordering of
these circles is vertical, so one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight, nine. But on
the right hand side, because it's rotated
90 degrees, the order is horizontal. So when
you getHomography function, you need to take
into account two things; you need to find
the position of the large blue circle and
once you know the position of the circle,
then you can order the points from the inputs,
such that you can rectify in the way that
you like.
So in my case I rectify it such that the X
and Y Cartesian co-ordinate is in the upper
left hand corner, but you can do something
different if you like, however if you do it
like this it makes it very easy to determine
all of the 2D position of the coloured shapes
in the image.
Okay so those are the two tasks that you have
to do this week. It's quite a complicated
week comparative to the last ones, but you
need to do the getCalibration function to
find the blue circles and you also need to
make a getHomography function to generate
a H matrix, such that you can get an image
that looks like this.